[Applause]
[Music]
how much do you miss Gwen and the boys
when you're out on the road that's
terrible I don't do a lot of these I do
I think we're doing 18 of these shows
this year and and so I try to limit it
as much as I can because the whole
reason I'm even stepping away from the
voice is is so I can just be there more
and that's what I'm going to do I love
though that no matter how far away you
are you always keep the family close I
saw you rocking that Mr Stefani Jean
genius isn't that funny I sent a picture
of it to Gwen and she said whatever you
do don't leave that there you've got to
bring that home I want that
before he heads home to Gwen and the
boys Blake's got 12 more shows on his
back to The Honky Tonk tour and he gave
us a peek pack stage what is it day in
the life like on tour for you when
you're heading to Stage what's your
mindset like right now usually I wake up
at the crack of noon any specific
warm-up routine that you do before you
hit the stage
alone
[Music]
you are the only country artist believe
it or not to have an actual bar set
around the stage what do you see when
you're up there you know I've seen a
little bit of everything I've seen
people literally face down passed out on
the bar clearly by the end of the show
and drool coming out on the table I've
seen people uh having a blast
you have bragging rights over Kelly
Clarkson and Justin Timberlake because
your bar setup is twice the size of the
bars that they had at theirs come on
Kelly come on Justin can't wuss out on
your your bar size man you got to step
it up can you say what's out on E.T
Cowboy Blake Shelton and of course
you're a TV star too you pick me as your
coach I will quit coaching after this
season has it hit you yet that your time
on The Voice is coming to an end
I think so I don't think it's really
going to hit me until
uh the last episode uh because when
you're in it you're in it there's been a
few moments especially the blind
auditions it dawned on me that's it I'm
never going to beg somebody to be on my
team again I'm never going to hit this
button again no I didn't cry or anything
because I don't cry
I'm a man it's probably going to be an
emotional night that last night I mean
my God it's been 23 12 years and I met
my wife on there you know it just
everything good that could come from
something like that it
I maxed it out
[Music]
okay